the era of the Airbus a380 superjumbo
passenger jet is coming to a close
the a380 took off for the first time in
2008 and seats 500 passengers the
company had hoped that the plane would
squeeze out Boeing 747 and
revolutionised air travel passengers
have always been big fans of the a380
and have given the plane high marks for
comfort space and for the quiet ride but
airlines have been cautious about
committing to the costly double-decker
planes and in the end they just weren't
willing to pay the massive price tag to
own the flying BM of the a380 had
troubles from the start
including tensions between air buses
French and German management and
protracted production delays and cost
overruns those prompted a company
restructuring that cost thousands of
jobs after Qantas canceled eight orders
and Emirates canceled 39 the company
says it will simply put an end to
production of the a380 by 2021 let's get
a bit more on the story and for that I'm
joined in the studio by Christophe Cobra
from DW business hello to you Christophe
so you know the a380 was of course quite
a remarkable achievement at least in its
day so why wasn't it a financial success
for Airbus there are several reasons for
that Mariana one the a380 is the world's
biggest jetliner we just saw there in
the report
it has about 550 seats in a regular
configuration and selling those seats to
passengers can be a challenging second
the a380 is for engines and they consume
a lot of fuel nowadays there are smaller
jets that can also go a long distance
but they only have two engines for that
matter it consumed in much less fuel and
the fuel cost is an issue with Airlines
and the third one is the aviation market
didn't develop as airbus anticipated so
rather than the passenger numbers
increasing on the route between the
major hubs of the world New York London
Paris Hong Kong Shanghai people want to
fly basically door-to-door if I want to
fly from Hamburg to Boston I want to go
direct without going through a major hub
and for the
sort of connections the a380 is simply
too big and you can see it that no major
airline in South America has bought it
no airline in Africa has bought it all
of them are going for smaller
long-distance planes
alright so efficiency seems to be a key
factor in these developments so if they
stopped building this jumbo jet what
will be the impact on the company it is
quite a blow to Airbus and taking the
billions of euros of development into
account
Airbus didn't make a cent on the a380
overall by this decision to end the
production about three hundred three
thousand five hundred workers are
impacted however Airbus says that the
backlog and orders particularly for its
mid-range jet a320 are so big that the
jobs can be shifted within the company
all right Christopher Cobra from DW
business thanks so much
you